hey everybody its Warren and this past
weekend the official Avengers end game
IMAX trailer came out so if you go see a
movie anytime soon you can go see an
IMAX movie and catch the Avengers
in-game trailer in IMAX The Avengers
end game IMAX trailer has a larger
aspect ratio meaning you can see more of
the picture so with the IMAX ratio
coming out for Avengers in game we got
to see a little bit more of each scene
in the trailer which has helped us find
some truth to an Avengers in game theory
the theory is about this scene in the
trailer right here where we see
somebody's hand touching the shoulder of
somebody else initially mostly everybody
thought this was nebula touching the
shoulder of Tony Stark but due to dim
lighting and the fact that you actually
can't see the face of the person sitting
in the chair
atheria was formed and it stated that
the person's arm was actually Natasha
Romanov and the person sitting in the
chair is actually Steve Rogers but the
IMAX ratio reveals more of the picture
in the scene which helps us solve the
question who is in the chair and whose
arm is touching the shoulder of that
person this picture right here is a
still from the IMAX Avengers in-game
trailer and as you can see the person in
the chair has a lot of stubble on his
face much like Tony does in the
beginning of the Avengers and game
trailer and of course as we saw in the
trailer Captain America is now
clean-shaven no beard not even a little
bit of stubble so it's clearly not
Captain America in this chair and the
stubble points to it being Tony Stark
and with the IMX ratio of this still you
can see the background even better than
you could in the trailer and in the
background you can see the curved window
which confirms that it's the
guardianship which is the benitar which
is the ship that Tony and nebula are on
so thanks to the IMAX ratio we have
confirmed that in the scene it is in
fact nebula touching the shoulder of
Tony Stark the real question now is what
exactly is going on in this scene the
way that nebula touches his shoulder it
seems like he's right on the verge of
dying or maybe he's already dead this is
a movie about time travel so he could
die in the beginning the Avengers go
back in time and alter time to make it
to where he eventually doesn't die but
let me know your thoughts on what you
think is happening
this scene right here with nebula
touching the shoulder of Tony Stark let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below and I'm still doing my giveaway
giving away a life-size Infinity
Gauntlet if you would like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]